ja was soll ich sagen für mich ist der
Kinderschutz und verhandelbar und hat
oberste Priorität und ich sehe das mit
Besorgnis wenn ich halt höre dass die
Ampel jetzt ein selbstbestimmungsgesetz
für die Kinder einfügen möchten dass die
Kinder selbst über ihr Geschlecht
entscheiden können
und vor allen Dingen habe ich da mal
eine ganz einfache Frage
da gibt es also Kinder die Kinder töten
der Fall Louise 13 jährige bringen
gezielt ein Kind um nachweislich haben
sich darüber informiert wie sie dieses
Kind wie sie jemanden töten können dass
er nicht erwischt werden da wird jetzt
nicht über diskutiert dass Kinder
vielleicht dass man Gesetz anpasst oder
wird diskutiert oder nicht gemacht das
heißt ein Kind weiß mit 14 mit 13 12
Monaten und 30 Tagen immer noch nicht
das Wort ein Verbrechen ist okay aber
wir wollen neuen zehnjährigen zugestehen
und sagen ihr könnt schon
entscheidend die Grünen gehen würde
würden wahrscheinlich schon mit drei
Jahren wählen können und da frage ich
mich bietet funktionieren soll und vor
allen Dingen halte ich es für sehr
bedenklich wenn ein
Gesundheitsministerium auch wenn sie
zurückgezogen haben Werbung für
irgendwelche pubertätsblocker macht
wenn jemand sich fühlt in einem falschen
Körper dann kann er bestimmte Dinge
machen wenn er es wirklich für sich auch
versteht und vereinbaren kann und ich
spreche da als jemand der unter der kann
jeder nachlesen ich habe mich schon Jazz
gekümmert Jess war ein Junge der ein
Mädchen sein wollte den man wo
anderthalb Jahren versucht hat diese
Mädchen
umzubringen umzubringen NRW tot zu Tode
zu treten auf ein Friedhof dieses
Mädchen
gekümmert und diese Mädchen wollte ein
Mädchen sein und dafür haben wir uns
eingesetzt das sind sein kann aber auch
ein gewisses Alter
weil man ja das ist auch ein Prozess
aber wenn man jetzt angreift bei Kindern
so früh und ich hatte letztens wieder
ich kriege ja sehr viele E-Mails wenn
mir jemand also schreibt dass ein Kind
in der Kita gefragt wird bist Du Junge
oder Mädchen und dieser Junge
nackt mit fünf Jahren ich bin ein Junge
und man sagt zu ihm als Pädagogen bist
du dir sicher dass du ein Junge bist
dann finde ich das in äußersten Maßen
bedenklich und ich habe manchmal das
Gefühl das ist das wäre nicht für diesen
Mainstream steht das wird jetzt das sind
einfach in ist man müsste das jetzt so
sein und von mir ist kann jeder jeder
sein Männlein Weiblein Waschmaschine
Fuchs jeder kann besser sein was er
möchte und einmal im Jahr könnte denn
ihr schlecht auch noch wechseln wenn das
alles so sein soll ist es so aber bei
den Kindern gibt es Grenzen und das ist
wieder eine Ideologie die übrigens aus
dem gleichen Haus kommt
die ich sehr bedenklich finde wo liegt
denn für sie die Altersgrenze das für
ein Kind das selbst entscheiden sollte
wenn es wirklich anfängt in die Pubertät
zu kommen und ob bestimmte Dinge zu
verstehen also wenn es 12 13 ist für
mich manche sind ein bisschen früher
helfen halt zwölf irgendwo in diesem
Bereich das merke ich ja an meiner
Tochter ist genau jetzt da ja sie sagen
also jetzt schon dass man mit 12 Jahren
nehmen kann aber da kann ein Kind
vielleicht wirklich wirklich realisieren
bin ich in einem falschen Körper fühle
ich mich aber während unter zehn wer
möchte denn unter zehn Dinge anhöre dass
du heute schon dass ich gesagt habe
schon eine Kita auf die Kinder einwirken
teilweise schon dort dran gehen ist es
gibt kein Gesetz nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein das nicht aber ich finde
es halt allein diese Tatsache es auf
eine Seite zu stellen und darüber zu
reden ihr könnt pubertätsblocker bringen
auf einer Seite eines eines
Familienministerium Gesundheitsminister
ist extrem wenn es doch nicht so wäre
warum haben Sie denn sofort wieder
zurückgezogen wir hören einmal rein beim
Tisch sind wir alle nicht betroffen
dementsprechend wollen wir einmal
reinhören zu einer betroffenen
wie waren das so für dich als die
irgendwie klar geworden ist ich bin
eigentlich gar kein Mädchen ich bin
junge ich glaub das war auch so
größtenteils im Kindergarten so früh
schon und dann ähm weil ich auch eher so
Lego gespielt habe
oder auch
draußen klettern war oder ähnliches mein
Ziel ist es eigentlich mehr zu werden
wie mein Bruder also du bist ein
richtiges Vorbild da hinten
[Gelächter]
ja das ist ein Ausschnitt aus der
Kindersendung Logo die auch für Kinder
ist und da sehen wir ja ein Mädchen das
ein Junge sein will und auch relativ
jung aussieht ähm Herr Stein genau das
meinen sie wahrscheinlich also wenn es
jetzt diese Entscheidung für sich hat
dann kann es ja diesen Weg weitergehen
und wenn es daran festhält und
irgendwann sich entscheidet darauf was
zu tun ist es ist okay aber ich habe
immer das Gefühl
diese Richtung wird genau das ist so
dahin gewöhnt so hingedrängt wird meine
wenn wir jetzt mal das Beispiel nehmen
also man sieht mich ja heute ich bin
noch ziemlich
Kräfte männliche Persönlichkeit also
auch ich habe übrigens mit Punkten
gespielt als ich fünf sechs Jahre alt
war habe ich gespielt und kannst du so
eine Puppen meine Mutter die ist
irgendwie meine Mutter habe so und was
nur weil ich jetzt mit der Puppe
gespielt hat und was haben sie mit denen
gespielt und was man dazu spielt
aber ich sehe immer noch die Bilder also
jetzt wird's nur weil ich das jetzt habe
ist ja jetzt ein elfjähriges Mädchen das
ein Junge sein will und das ist ja auch
schon weiter als mit Puppen spielen
sondern sagt ich will ein Junge sein ist
das jetzt sein möchte und so für sich
entscheiden wirklich entscheidet aber
die Frage ist wann greift man ein dass
irgendwas zu verändern dass man
pubertäter schluckt oder wo man anfängt
vielleicht auch chirurgische Eingriffe
zu machen weil eins darf man nicht
vergessen dass ich ja nicht mehr
rückkehrbar ja und das ist es wenn ich
jetzt an Jesse zum Beispiel denke das
Mädchen was da fast tot geprügelt wurde
die ist die wird jetzt 16 das ist eine
ganz andere und die hält daran fest die
bildet auch und macht jetzt bestimmte
Dinge auf einen Grund auf einen Punkt
gebracht ja Geschlechter ändern ist gut
wenn man das möchte aber nicht zu früh
hat nicht zu viel weil jeder sollte das
sein ja also da habe ich überhaupt kein
Problem mit aber so ab 12 okay davor
nicht
vom Kind zu Kind auch noch Einschätzung
sein aber ich bin jetzt nicht derjenige
der das einschätzt ich finde bloß wenn
man heute schon mitbekommt dass in Kitas
oder in Schulen so drauf eingewirkt wird
ich habe doch gerade dieses Beispiel
genannt und das höre ich nicht zum
ersten Mal dann finde ich es schon ein
bisschen bedenklich wie man da äh schon
so ein sowas aufbringt als wenn das das
schwul schwule gibt alles schön gut aber
zu sagen zum Kind zu sagen bist du
sicher das sind dass du ein Junge bist
und so also schon diese Verunsicherung
reinzubringen halte ich für falsch und
da sehe ich halt immer sehr viel
Ideologie und Wunsch standen und das
finde ich einfach sollte man
zumindestens Bedenken dabei und ich
würde mir das für meine Kinder verbieten
dass man so oft sind die Jüngste in der
Runde deswegen komme ich jetzt nach
Carsten Stahl jetzt zu ihnen ich wollte
nicht unterbrechen aber ich würde sehr
gerne was dazu äußern und zwar glaube
ich dass es ein bisschen entspannter von
ihrer Seite aus betrachtet werden sollte
weil ich glaube es geht eher um diese
Offenheit dass die Kinder nicht Angst
haben etwas zu äußern was Sie vielleicht
Angst macht weil alle anderen sie
auslachen weil sie keine richtigen
Rollenbilder haben weil sie niemanden so
richtig kennen der das irgendwie so
toleriert oder der irgendwie ist die die
brauchen diese Offenheit dieses das ist
glaube ich eine andere Perspektive die
sie da einnehmen also ich verstehe es
einigermaßen aber ich denke mir das ist
ja es geht eher dieses Angst nehmen
zu sagen ich weiß es nicht wie weit sie
meine Arbeit kennen ich gehe an Schulen
und hatte über 100.000 Schüler und mache
Prävention Seminare für Respekt und
Toleranzen gegen Mobbing jeden Tag stehe
ich an Schulen und sage dass man sich
dass sich jeder so sein darf wie er ist
und diese Vorteile nicht da sind das ist
das ist vollkommen Geld
man dass die Kinder auch die Chance
haben nicht zu outen dass sie anders
sind alles okay dass da auch eine
Toleranz und Respekt herrschen muss ich
finde bloß diese diese dieses von oben
schon auf eingewirke und auf Kinder die
noch überhaupt nicht wirklich eine
Meinung haben das zuzuordnen das finde
ich das finde ich bedenklich dass es so
ist wenn ein Kind in der Schule ankommt
ich sage ich möchte lieber ein Mädchen
sein dann unter diesen Weg weitergehen
möchte aber was ist es wenn es heute
Mädchen sein möchte und in zwei Jahren
trainiert werden das ist das ist dieses
induktionierte ansonsten vorbei schaut
euch die Geschichte mit Jess an der
Seite ich war die ich gleich geholfen
habe aus dem Rollstuhl die hatten die
hatte die war Kurzform von vom Tod wie
wir sie wieder aufgebaut haben dass sie
heute da steht und sagt ich bin ein
Mädchen
zu dem zu der These zu dem Zeit zurück
Frau wolowitsch kennen sie denn Menschen
die ihr Geschlecht gewechselt haben also
die Menschen die ich kenne wussten von
vornherein von vorne rein also selbst in
einem Alter von ich glaube das merkst du
einfach ich glaube Menschen muss es
nicht verstehen können weil sie
heterosexuell sind weil sie sich ihrem
genetischen Geschlecht zugehörig fühlen
können es gar nicht das ist so ein
Gefühl entweder fühlst du es oder du
fühlst es nicht und ich kenne Menschen
diesen Schwanz ist ganz wichtig mit
circa fünf Jahren schon irgendwie
wussten aber immer noch so ein bisschen
sich zum Beispiel ich kenne eine
Freundin von mir das kann ich erzählen
die kommt aus Weißrussland
selbstbestimmungsgesetz ist gut genau
und die hat erst mit
keine Ahnung vielleicht mit 21 oder mit
22 wirklich das ausleben können weil sie
in weißrussell kann sich vorstellen und
dann dem Vater der auch im Militär ist
und so die musste
ins Militär musste alles das machen was
sie als Frau niemals machen ganz ganz
schlimme Beispiel aber es gibt natürlich
auch die Fakten und das zeigen vor allem
auch Studien aus England das auch
Menschen gibt die später die
Geschlechtsumwandlung bereuen und die
später merken sind im falschen Körper
und wir hatten hier auch ein sehr
beeindruckende Frau sabbelt blank die
auch das bereut und was man ja auch
nicht verschönern darf denke ich dass es
immer wichtig ist zu sagen Mediziner
weisen ja auch darauf hin man nimmt ja
dann sein ganzes Leben lang Medikamente
also ja nicht mal eben man wechselt sein
Geschlecht dann ist ja mein ganzes Leben
lang schon auch gesundheitlich bei
einschränkt deswegen wie sehen sie den
Regelungen zu dem Thema weil ich denke
hier ist keiner am Tisch der sagt man
darf es aber nicht tun oder aber wie
würden sie es machen dass die richtigen
Entscheidung getroffen werden können und
zwar dass man wirklich auch später noch
sich gut fühlt mit der
Geschlechtsumwandlung oder mit dem
pubertätsblockern
also ich bin der Meinung man sollte
immer noch diese Möglichkeit haben dass
man es selber entscheiden darf also
jeder sollte das Recht haben zu
entscheiden ob er eine Frau Mann nicht
binär oder was auch immer sein möchte
wenn man sich falsch entscheidet
dann ist es halt die Schuld der Person
die sich dafür entscheidet das muss man
sich wirklich gut überlegen es ist schön
das ist also ich finde das Thema
wirklich schwierig aber die sehen ja
diese pubertätsblocker heißen ja
pubertätsblocker weil sie vor der
Pubertät eingesetzt werden um die Puppe
Tee zu blocken dass ich dann eben als
Frau keine Brüste bekommen und so weiter
aber das heißt doch da muss die
Entscheidung ja in einem in einem Alter
gefällt werden wo man glaube ich so eine
weitreichende Entscheidung auf keinem
Fall dem Kind nur alleine anvertrauen
kann das ist ja das ist das was ich
meine es geht ja darum
krass falsch absolut falscher Weg ja es
geht gibt ja die Tendenz dazu ähm auch
in dieser gesetzlichen Regelungen nicht
jetzt so krass über die Tendenz dass man
eben den Eltern die eigentlich
letztendlich das Sorgerecht haben die da
auch so ein bisschen entmachten will und
mehr dem kindeswunsch stark gerecht zu
werden das ist kann in manchen Fällen
sicherlich notwendig sein und so aber
generell halte ich das auch für
gefährlich weil wir reden doch auch also
ich habe da die altmodische Vorstellung
dass mein Körper halt nun mal so ist wie
er ist und wenn ich gerne Frauenkleider
anziehe bin ich froh dass wir inzwischen
eine Gesellschaft haben wo das möglich
ist ich könnte jetzt hier auch im Kleid
bei ihnen denke ich auftreten hoffe ich
ja absolute das nächste mal so ich muss
ja deswegen muss ich doch nicht mich
operieren ist auch kein Problem krasse
Medikamente schlucken und und so das
finde ich
die richtige Beratung um die gute
Psychologen rein den fehlt in der Runde
hier ich kenne einen Fall also das ist
ein Junge der hat offensichtlich so
genau in welche Richtung sich bewegen
soll und der läuft dann zu Hause halt
oder am Wochenende läuft er halt
lackierten Fingernägel Handtaschen
aber in der Schule geht ganz normal er
geht in die Schule ganz normal auch aus
dem Grund um einfach Stresssituationen
zu werden
ja also das ist und was ich mich an
dieser ganzen Diskussion wirklich ein
bisschen erschreckt also wir haben ja
ein Jugendstrafrecht das
Jugendstrafrecht geht davon aus dass wir
es bei jugendlichen Straftätern erst ab
14 Uhr übrigens ist mir eine Strafe
nicht ähm mit noch nicht voll
entwickelten Persönlichkeiten haben
müssen anders die müssen anders
behandelt werden als Erwachsene weil man
ihn natürlich noch ein gewisses
Entwicklungspotenzial erkennt jetzt ist
natürlich völlig grotesk also im
Jugendstrafrecht gehen wir davon aus
dass sind Persönlichkeiten
ausgebildet sind und jetzt auf einmal
zehnjährigen an zu sagen die können aber
so eine Entscheidung treffen es ist für
mich nur ein Wort noch es ist für mich
eine völlig klare Geschichte also jemand
kann erst ab 18 so eine Entscheidung
treffen die kann er dann ja hat auch
Zeit sich zu überlegen und das Problem
ist
Jugendliche oder Kinder sowieso was
lernen die im Kindergarten oder
Grundschule die müssen natürlich einen
Rollenverständnis entwickeln das ist
heute viel komplizierter als zu meiner
Jugend mit sieben acht oder so also das
war einfach die 70er Jahre
da gab es noch festgekühlte Rollenmuster
und alles da konntest du mitmachen oder
nicht und wer halt nicht irgendwie sich
zugehörig fühlte hatte schon massives
Problem das gibt's ja heute nicht aber
heute ist es ja viel schwieriger für
Jungs die männlich Identität zu
entwickeln was ist schon eine männliche
Identität heute für Frauen weibliche
Identität was schon alles für
problematisiert und Kinder werden
natürlich mit diesen wahnsinnigen
Medienkonsum den sie haben also ich kann
ja heute wahrscheinlich tausende Videos
zu diesem Thema runterladen die gucken
sich dann alle an wir sind natürlich
nicht aufklärerisch sondern die
verwirren dich jetzt noch mehr und man
muss dann einfach die Chance geben sich
zu entwickeln und da ist die Frage
welches gesellschaftliche Leitbild
wollen wir wollen wir haben das ist
nicht mehr das Leitbild meiner Eltern
aus den 50er Jahren bei der vor dem
Krieg geboren
sondern heute modernes Leitbild und
dieses modernen Leitbild kann aber nicht
auf klare Planken verzichten und das
bedeutet einfach lebe dich aus Spiel mit
Puppen ich glaube heute wird keiner mehr
im Kindergarten angeguckt vielleicht
aber doch ich nicht so richtig beurteilt
wenn er mit Puppen spielt oder mit dem
Kleid rumläuft aber es machen natürlich
auch ganz wenige Kinder das ganz wenige
Jungs kommen mit dem Kleid im
Kindergarten oder eine Grundschule habe
ich persönlich so noch nicht erlebt wer
das für sie ein Problem nein warum aber
das Problem bekommt er natürlich in
seinem im Umfeld seiner Klasse wir haben
ja heute schon wahnsinnige massive
Probleme überhaupt die Kinder zu
beschulen das Mobbing ja mein Thema fast
schon Alltag 1,5 Millionen Fälle jede
Woche
jetzt ist mein
wie würden Sie Ihr Abschluss Plädoyer
was sie gerne hätten Deutschland was wir
ändern müssen was wir tun sollten ja
also ich finde es ist ganz wichtig dass
wir über das Thema natürlich sprechen
aber ich finde einfach dass man nicht zu
früh damit anfangen sollte das was wir
da gehört haben dann auch noch weil es
in einem anderen landgeschehen ist wo
sowieso noch andere Werte vermittelt
werden steinige Werte das ist absolut
falsch ich habe zu meinen Kinder ich
habe nur zwei Kinder genau da drin sind
immer gesagt zumindestens absolut so 19
Mann ihr dürft alles sein was ihr
möchtet ich werde mich ich werde immer
auf eurer Seite sehen ihr könnt euch so
entwickeln wie ihr wollt so und wenn sie
deine Entscheidung hätten getroffen dann
hätte ich Sie dabei unterstützt wenn es
ihren Entscheidung ist aber wie oft ist
eine Entscheidung getroffen die nach bei
Kindern ganz besonders nach einer kurzen
Zeit wieder umgeworfen wurde und da
irgendwelche Blogger zu nehmen wo man
noch nicht mal die Risiken wissen was
daraus entsteht finde ich den falschen
Weg und umso früh einzusetzen und da war
er gerade beim gleichen Beispiel wie ich
gesagt habe also für morgen sind sie
nicht zu rechnungsfähig aber das können
Sie entscheiden da passt was nicht aber
grundsätzlich und das ist mir immer
wichtig wir müssen für eine respektvolle
tolerante und gute Welt entstehen und
dann müssen wir jeden akzeptieren wir
ist egal ob sie dem einen oder anderen
gefällt oder nicht aber zu früh anfangen
sollten wir damit nicht vielleicht